Cynthia is with us in Charleston South
Carolina hi Cynthia how are you I'm
awesome how are you
just the same how can I help I'm a
question I have a for a retirement
account I have an indexed universal life
with a death benefit and is that
something I know you don't like whole
life policy is that Index universal
licensing you would keep no no and
here's a simple thing when you combine
investing and life insurance together
the investments never perform like they
should because they get feed to death as
they walk down the hallway of the life
insurance company that's what it comes
down to and the insurance ends up being
expensive because it's all wrapped
together and it's very hard to undo it
unless you really know a lot about the
business it's very hard to take the two
parts of the investment part and the and
the insurance stuff apart and look at
them and go wow that sucks ooh that
sucks oh this thing double sucks you
know and and that's but I've been doing
it for years and so here's what it comes
down to the indexed investment is going
into index funds typically sometimes
it's going into other mutual funds but
either way that though if you went
straight to those mutual funds you would
make better rates of return because you
wouldn't be paying extra fees that
you're paying with the insurance product
is that logical yeah okay and then the
the usually in a universal life not
every time but most every time the
insurance side of the product is what's
called a RT annual renewable term now
let me talk that through with you just
because it's kind of nerdy and fun okay
life insurance the older you get it
costs more to cover you because you're
more likely to die statistically does
that make sense
mm-hmm so a 56 year old pays more than a
55 year old who pays more than a 45 year
old because my older you are
statistically on average are more likely
to die duh right so the pure insurance
is
is every year it goes up based on your
increased likelihood to die
that's pure insurance does that make
sense to you yeah that that more
accurately reflects the actual
statistics now that's called annual
renewable term now here's what's
interesting about life the life
insurance world though you hear me talk
about fifteen year or 20 year level term
which means you pay one price every year
the same price level for fifteen whole
years it didn't go up which what that
tells you if you think about it for a
second is all they did was take the
average of the of the prices through the
increase instead of going up every time
for fifteen times they just took the
average of that and they charge you one
price okay that makes sense and however
one of the big costs of life insurance
is not just someone dying for the
insurance company one of the big costs
is the commissions and so if a type of
policy will stay on their books longer
than another type it's cheaper for them
and that cost is typically passed on to
you the consumer in lower premiums
fifteen year policies stay on the books
a lot better than annual renewable terms
and term does and so a fifteen year on
average over the fifteen years is going
to be not just the average but it's
going to be cheaper does that make sense
to you mm-hmm
okay now then you take that AR t over
there and you say oh this universal life
basically I'm paying one price some of
its going to investing some of its going
to insurance but the portion that's
going to insurance goes up every year
therefore the amount going to
investments goes down every year that
makes sense yep that sucks too I mean if
you just think about it I don't want to
be putting less in investments I want to
be putting more in investments and and
they're doing they're going with the
most expensive type of way to calculate
the insurance because of the averages so
that's a lot of gobbledygook but if you
got half of it you're starting to see
why this doesn't work you're better off
to buy term insurance and do your
investing straight into your 401k into
good mutual funds or in
your Roth IRA into good mutual funds
without it being wrapped up and bundled
up inside of an insurance product is
that logical to you yes so what would
you suggest that I move it into well it
sounds like you're buying it inside of a
retirement plan at work or something
well it's it's uh it's not through work
it's through somebody that it comes out
of my checking so it's after-tax okay so
you just bought it from an insurance
broker yeah okay but so it's not in an
IRA no he said it's indexed universal
life
you just bought a life insurance policy
yeah it's not a retirement plan at all
it's just a way of investing money
poorly that's all it is okay what's real
simple
get get with Zander Insurance Zander is
calm and and get a quote for term life
insurance you should have 10 to 12 times
your income on you and if you're married
the same amount on your husband he
should have 10 to 12 times his income on
him get that term insurance in place
before you do anything and then just
cancel this stuff and then it's going to
save you a ton of money ton of money and
that will enable you then to invest into
your into your Roth IRA and some good
mutual funds I have life insurance
through work okay but I still need to
get um how much do you have to work um
well I guess it well I don't actually
know okay well that's the thing to find
out you need about 10 to 12 times on you
if you've got that much at work you
probably ought to get a policy outside
of work anyway not necessarily a huge
one but some because if you ever got
some kind of a medical event like a
cancer scare or got diabetes or heart
problem or something like that and then
you left work you would leave your
insurance back there at work and you
wouldn't be insurable for new life
insurance out in the marketplace so we
always recommend you have some outside
of work but usually you have one to five
times your income in your group plan at
work which is not enough so you probably
want to supplement that outside but all
I'm saying is don't cancel this
universal life even though I don't like
it until you have other insurance in
place because I don't want you to die in
between
leave a mess right so just get the right
assurance some insurance in place then
cancel this stuff and then you can sit
down at we know with your investment
professional and get a real investment
going directly into mutual funds into a
Roth IRA and it will do just do a whole
lot better but you know basically the
universal life is a it's the same thing
as whole life it's a more modern version
but after the fees the average universal
life indexed and everything after fees
not their quoted rates not what their
brochures say but the real world when
the actual research is done this is the
amount of money should have gone to
insurance this amount of money should
have gone into the investment and then
we can back out and we can actually
mathematically calculate what the
investment return is on average it's
about four point seven percent or the
average mutual fund is ten to twelve
percent and so that tells you that that
money is going somewhere other than to
you that's what it amounts to just a bad
product that's when it comes down to
this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income a five hundred thousand dollar
income